sorprendente éxito de los poderes
tradicionales de la política francesa
el partido conservador los republicanos
salió de nuevo a flote y la izquierda
del partido socialista se mantuvo firme
la izquierda radical la extrema derecha
sufrieron resultados decepcionantes la
agrupación nacional de marine lepén
alcanzó resultados por debajo de lo
esperado en casi todos los ámbitos en
estas elecciones regionales las
encuestas señalaban la semana pasada que
su partido podría alzarse con la
victoria en seis regiones pero sólo lo
consiguió en una y obtuvo menos del 20
por ciento del voto nacional un
retroceso que lepén achacó a la
abstención récord el domingo más de 6
personas sobre 10 no acudieron a votar
como publiquen son como republicana sólo
puedo lamentar este desastre cívico que
ha deformado en la realidad electoral de
todo el país y produjo una impresión
engañosa de la actual correlación de
fuerzas políticas entre tanto el partido
conservador los republicanos se alzó con
la victoria con más del 27 por ciento
del voto nacional su candidato en la
norteña región altos de francia xavier
bertrand tuvo un gran resultado
consiguiendo casi la victoria en esta
ronda una victoria que para él es un
signo de que su partido es el baluarte
más efectivo contra la extrema derecha
un deseo de pury y si esta noche
rebajamos la fuerza del frente nacional
es de demagogia sus propuestas estériles
su intolerancia todo lo que divide y que
representa el frente nacional y tus que
luz conexión al en la izquierda el
partido socialista y los verdes ganaron
más de lo esperado consiguiendo
respectivamente cerca del 15 y el 13 por
ciento del voto nacional el partido
socialista incluso podría hacerse con el
poder en cinco regiones para él manuel
macrón fue una noche dura en comparativa
su partido es joven no existía en las
anteriores regionales de 2015 y se notó
al nivel departamental y regional no
consiguió ni una sola región a pesar de
que 13 de los candidatos eran ministros
del gobierno de macrón sólo alcanzaron
el quinto puesto a nivel nacional con
poco más del 10 por ciento de los votos